Animals live in many different places.
Some live above the ground.
Some live in the ground.
Some live on the ground.
Some live in the water.
This bird lives in the trees.
The monkey lives in the trees, too.
This frog lives in a pond.
The turtle lives in a pond, too.
This prairie dog lives in a burrow.
The woodchuck lives in a burrow, too.
These bats live in a cave.
This bear lives in a cave, too.
This deer lives in the woods.
The fox lives in the woods, too.
This octopus lives in the ocean.
The whale lives in the ocean, too.
Mandy and Michael live in a house.
People are animals, too.
Where does the bird live?
The bird lives in the trees.
Where does the monkey live?
The monkey lives in the trees, too.
Where does the sloth live?
The sloth also lives in the trees.